listening to your heartbeat realizing it's my heartbeat too cause if something were to happen to you listening to your breathing realizing it's my breathing too because if something were to happen to you Hi, welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. I'm here with Dr. Haley Beach and Dr. Madeleine Eckenrode. Haley is a doctor of philosophy and social work. Dr. Eckenrode is a medical doctor who just wrote an article that we saw on ale.com about Medicaid expansion and some of the
聆听你的心跳，意识到那也是我的心跳，因为如果你出了什么事，聆听你的呼吸，意识到那也是我的呼吸，因为如果你出了什么事。你好，欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。我和 Haley Beach 博士以及 Madeleine Eckenrode 博士在一起。Haley 拥有社会工作博士学位。Eckenrode 博士是一位医学博士，她刚刚在 ale.com 上发表了一篇关于医疗补助（Medicaid）扩张的文章，以及一些
effects of not having access to health care on women and young adults. I will let you lead us in because we want to kind of look at the way that some of these things affect Alabamians and probably people in other states too, with similar realities and hear from the people who provide care about that. Dr. Mr. James Waits at our practice sees his specialty as physician burnout and nurses and executives and doctors. And so he may pop in if he's able to. And you know, Haley's specialty, well, Haley,
无法获得医疗保健对女性和年轻人造成的影响。我会让你来引导我们，因为我们想看看其中一些事情对阿拉巴马州人，以及其他州有着类似现实的人们的影响，并听听提供护理的人对此的看法。我们诊所的 James Waits 先生将医生倦怠、护士、高管和医生视为他的专业领域。所以如果他能来的话，他可能会加入。你知道，Haley 的专业，嗯，Haley，
can you talk about your work just so we know where everyone's coming from before we start the discussion? Yeah. Yeah. So my work really focuses on looking at birthing, birthing individuals, women who experience violence and women who experience trauma through their birthing experience prior and after. And so my work is really focused on that academically and professionally as a therapist wanting to work with that population, those women, but also interested in young adults and how they receive care and how they, they are able to navigate mental health in a time of life
你能谈谈你的工作吗？这样在我们开始讨论之前，我们就能知道每个人的背景。好的。好的。我的工作确实专注于关注生育、生育个体、经历过暴力的女性，以及在生育经历前后经历过创伤的女性。因此，我的工作在学术上和作为一名想要与该群体（那些女性）合作的治疗师的专业层面上，确实专注于这一点，但也对年轻人以及他们在人生中如何接受护理，以及他们如何能够应对心理健康感兴趣，
that can be very complex. Yeah, and so, and then I do, you know, trauma therapy and so we're all kind of looking at similar, similar population from different angles, similar issue from different angles. So just to make sure everyone knows where we're coming from. So Dr. Ekenharn, could you tell us a little bit about your article and some of your perspective working at UAB and what you see there and
这可能非常复杂。是的，而且我做的是创伤治疗，所以我们都在从不同的角度审视相似的群体，从不同的角度审视相似的问题。所以为了确保每个人都知道我们的背景。那么 Eckenrode 博士，你能告诉我们一点关于你的文章，以及你在 UAB 工作的一些观点，你在那里看到了什么，以及
the effect that it has on just real people's lives? Sure. Yeah. So I am a med-peds physician. So I did a dual residency in internal medicine, so kind of adult medicine and pediatrics. And so graduated in 2015 or in 2019 from residency at UAB, did my training there. And then I now do mostly adult primary care. And so but I also specialize in young adults with complex medical conditions. So I have a clinic at UAB called the Step Clinic, where we see young adults who have very complex medical conditions from childhood, things like cerebral palsy, spina bifida,
它对普通人生活的影响吗？当然。好的。我是一名内科-儿科医生。所以我完成了内科（成人医学）和儿科的双重住院医师培训。2015 年或 2019 年从 UAB 的住院医师项目毕业，并在那里完成了我的培训。我现在主要从事成人初级保健。但我还专门研究患有复杂疾病的年轻人。我在 UAB 有一个名为 Step Clinic 的诊所，我们在那里接待患有儿童期复杂疾病的年轻人，比如脑瘫、脊柱裂，
but also kids who have had organ transplants, kids who have had, who have complicated immunologic things like lupus, things like that. So I see a lot of those young adults in my practice at UAB as well. And so, yeah, I really see the impact of underinsurance or lack of insurance every day in my life, in my practice. So I guess I wrote the article, I think, after years of kind of being like, why hasn't this
还有接受过器官移植的孩子，患有复杂免疫系统疾病（如狼疮等）的孩子。所以我在 UAB 的诊所也看到了很多这样的年轻人。所以，是的，我每天在我的生活中、在我的诊所里都能看到保险不足或缺乏保险的影响。所以我想我写这篇文章，是在多年来一直想“为什么还没发生？”之后，
happened? Why haven't we expanded Medicaid? Because I just see how it impacts my patients every day. And I think I think I was talking to an organization called Alabama Arise that does advocacy around lots of issues that affect Alabamans, including the lack of Medicaid expansion here, and was talking to them about this patient population of young adults. And they were like, oh wow, this is something we haven't thought about. So young adults who have chronic conditions of childhood, things like Crohn's disease,
为什么我们还没有扩大医疗补助？因为我每天都能看到它如何影响我的病人。我想我当时正在与一个名为 Alabama Arise 的组织交谈，该组织围绕许多影响阿拉巴马州人的问题进行倡导，包括这里缺乏医疗补助扩张，并与他们谈论了这个年轻人患者群体。他们说，哦，哇，这是我们没想到的。所以那些患有儿童期慢性疾病（如克罗恩病）的年轻人，
or they've had an organ transplant or type one diabetes, and then they lose pediatric Medicaid at age 19 unless they have parents who have health insurance that they're able to be covered under. And so they were like, this is an interesting population to write about. You should consider doing an op-ed. And so I did.
或者他们接受过器官移植或患有 1 型糖尿病，然后他们在 19 岁时失去了儿科医疗补助，除非他们的父母有他们可以被覆盖的健康保险。所以他们说，这是一个值得撰写的有趣群体。你应该考虑写一篇评论文章。所以我写了。
And it was published and had a really, I think, good response from people who I think a lot of, I got a lot of emails and pages and messages from colleagues who were like, I'm so glad you talked about this because it's something that is very real. We see it every day. And so I've been really gratified to hear that response from people who are like, this is an issue that is under discussed.
它发表了，而且我认为从人们那里得到了非常好的反响，我收到了很多同事的电子邮件、页面和信息，他们说，我很高兴你谈到了这一点，因为这是一件非常真实的事情。我们每天都能看到。所以我很高兴听到人们的回应，他们说，这是一个讨论不足的问题。
Well, and I'm glad to see more medical professionals, especially doctors who are kind of the top of the food chain for the medical establishment talking about that because I think not talking about it leads to these kind of confusions about like, I mean, a lot of people that I encounter, we've all as Americans probably had pain points with the medical system. I don't know that anyone is loving it. Or like any kind of political advertisement that pretends that like people love the healthcare
嗯，我很高兴看到更多的医疗专业人员，特别是那些处于医疗机构食物链顶端的医生在谈论这个问题，因为我认为不谈论它会导致这种困惑，比如，我遇到的很多人，我们作为美国人可能都对医疗系统有痛点。我不知道有谁喜欢它。或者像任何假装人们喜欢医疗保健系统的政治广告一样。
system. It doesn't make sense to me. Like I remember when Obamacare was first being discussed and people were like, your precious insurance plan, you might lose it. Don't we all curl up by the fire with our insurance plan every night and hug it and kiss it on the forehead. And it was like, cable companies, airlines, insurance. These are things that I don't know
这对我来说没有意义。就像我记得奥巴马医改刚开始讨论时，人们说，你珍贵的保险计划，你可能会失去它。难道我们不是每天晚上都蜷缩在火炉旁，抱着我们的保险计划，亲吻它的额头吗？就像有线电视公司、航空公司、保险公司。这些是我不知道
that anyone's having a great experience with. But I think a lot of that anger gets directed at doctors in ways that aren't fair by people who don't really understand how that system works. And it makes sense because the doctor is the one telling you, I don't have time to see you, or the, you know, scheduling for UAB is the one telling you, Oh, yeah, there's something seven months from now if you want to get a referral for therapy, but you have to have primary care first, which is Blue Car's Blue Shield's decision, but it feels like the white coat is out to get me. And a lot of that, I mean, I understand the reason you wouldn't wanna talk about some of these things, but it seems like the response to your article has been good.
有谁有很好体验的事情。但我认为很多愤怒以不公平的方式指向了医生，由那些并不真正了解该系统如何运作的人发出。这说得通，因为医生是那个告诉你“我没时间看你”的人，或者 UAB 的预约人员告诉你，“哦，是的，如果你想获得心理治疗转诊，七个月后有空位，但你必须先进行初级保健”，这是蓝十字蓝盾（Blue Cross Blue Shield）的决定，但感觉就像是白大褂在针对我。关于这一点，我的意思是，我理解你为什么不想谈论其中一些事情，但看起来对你文章的回应很好。
I wonder if you could say anything about that engagement, good and bad, and the conversations that maybe you see. Yeah, yeah, I think that's right. I think there's been a loss of trust towards doctors and that's very complicated and we don't, that's not kind of the topic of this conversation, but yeah, I think that being transparent about some of the struggles
我想知道你是否能谈谈那种参与，好的和坏的，以及你可能看到的对话。是的，是的，我认为那是对的。我认为对医生的信任已经丧失，这非常复杂，我们不，这不是这次谈话的主题，但是的，我认为对我们照顾病人的挣扎保持透明是好的。
that we have to care for our patients effectively is good. So patients know that. And I always try to be honest with patients. And I think that a lot of times patients think that anything we say can overcome insurance company barriers. And that's not always the case. And so it's often not the case.
这样病人们就知道了。我总是尽量对病人诚实。而且我认为很多时候病人认为我们说的任何话都能克服保险公司的障碍。事实并非总是如此。所以情况往往并非如此。
And I've literally cried on the phone with insurance companies during prior authorizations because I'm like like if you deny this like this patient might die and like and then usually it does get approved but like then I have to like cry like that's crazy like um but anyway yeah so um well and why are you the one telling them you know what I mean one why are they why are they the one telling you that you need to change your medical care as the one who's licensed to provide it and has the encounter with the patient and the access to the test
在预先授权期间，我曾真的在电话里对保险公司哭过，因为我说，如果你拒绝这个，这个病人可能会死，然后通常它确实会被批准，但之后我不得不哭，这太疯狂了，但无论如何，是的，所以，嗯，为什么是你告诉他们，你明白我的意思吗？为什么是他们告诉你，你需要改变你的医疗护理，作为那个有执照提供护理、与病人接触并能获得检查结果的人，
results and you know, like all the healthcare data? And then why are you the one begging them to explaining to them that the patient might die? I mean, what is that system? I don't know. And like prior authorizations required for like generic medicines like albuterol, you know, it's like albuterol is a life-saving medicine. It's a generic medicine. It's been around for 50 years. Like, why do I have to like-
你知道，比如所有的医疗保健数据？然后为什么是你乞求他们，向他们解释病人可能会死？我的意思是，那是什么系统？我不知道。而且像沙丁胺醇（albuterol）这样的通用药物也需要预先授权，你知道，沙丁胺醇是一种救命药。它是一种通用药物。它已经存在 50 年了。为什么我必须……
It's not even expensive. Why are you gouging that? I don't know. Yeah, so it's really crazy. And I probably do like four hours of paperwork every week related to medication, kind of prior authorization and stuff like that. And so I and that just stinks. But yeah, so insurance, yeah, insurance kind of is the enemy as far as I'm concerned. In terms of preventing good care
它甚至不贵。你们为什么要敲诈？我不知道。是的，这真的很疯狂。我每周可能要做四个小时与药物相关的文书工作，比如预先授权之类的。所以，这真的很糟糕。但是的，所以保险，是的，就我而言，保险就是敌人。在防止为病人提供良好的护理方面，
for patients and, you know, huge money making corporations that don't care about patients at all. You know, I think a lot of stuff about United Health Care that has come out is is is true and is bad. Like there was just a ProPublica article about how they in certain states use algorithms to see how if people are using too much mental health care. And then they start to use the United United Health healthcare in certain states. It's been outlawed in a handful of states But in certain states they they look at at yeah Healthcare claims by individual and if they're using too much healthcare and mental health care so getting too much therapy You know is there too much?
而且，你知道，巨大的赚钱公司根本不关心病人。你知道，我认为关于联合健康保险（United Health Care）曝光的很多事情都是真实的，而且很糟糕。就像最近有一篇 ProPublica 的文章，关于他们在某些州如何使用算法来查看人们是否使用了太多的心理健康护理。然后他们开始使用联合健康保险。在少数几个州这已被取缔，但在某些州，他们查看个人的医疗索赔，如果他们使用了太多的医疗保健和心理健康护理，也就是接受了太多的治疗，
It's such a thing but they think there is and then they start denying their claims Which as you know for people was like serious psychiatric illness like schizophrenia, they need a lot of care. It's bipolar, where you're clinging to your ability to make good decisions before you go into mania and they can feel it and they're begging for help. I mean, those are the cruelest phone calls we get because I can't prescribe medication. I can tell you how long the wait is and that is dour answer. Exactly. So that was just revealed
你知道，有太多这种说法吗？但他们认为有，然后他们开始拒绝他们的索赔，正如你所知，对于患有严重精神疾病（如精神分裂症）的人来说，他们需要大量的护理。这是双相情感障碍，在你进入躁狂状态之前，你正紧紧抓住自己做出正确决定的能力，他们能感觉到，他们正在乞求帮助。我的意思是，那些是我们接到的最残酷的电话，因为我无法开处方。我只能告诉你等待时间有多长，而那是一个令人沮丧的答案。正是如此。所以这刚刚被揭露，
that they're doing this in certain states and have algorithms to look at these claims. So anyway, they're the enemy as far as I'm concerned. However, people do need insurance to get care and out of the Medicaid is actually fairly decent in terms of at least prescription drug coverage. So I see this happen a lot where people, they like fall off and on Medicaid, especially young women. in terms of at least prescription drug coverage. So I see this happen a lot where people,
他们在某些州这样做，并有算法来查看这些索赔。所以无论如何，就我而言，他们是敌人。然而，人们确实需要保险才能获得护理，而医疗补助在处方药覆盖方面实际上相当不错。所以我经常看到这种情况发生，人们，他们像是在医疗补助上进进出出，尤其是年轻女性。
they like fall off and on Medicaid, especially young women. You've probably seen this, Hailey, who have babies and then they're on Medicaid for that time and they get a little bit of access to care. And then that Medicaid goes away. And so then their health suffers. And so people, I see that in my practice a lot. I'll see people for a couple of years,
在处方药覆盖方面至少是这样。所以我经常看到这种情况，人们，
and then I won't see them for a year or two because they've lost insurance. And then their diabetes becomes really poorly controlled. And it's like, why do we have that? Why can't we have a system where people can get care when they have job loss or when they're having to care for a relative or when they have a serious illness themselves
他们像是在医疗补助上进进出出，尤其是年轻女性。你可能见过这种情况，Hailey，那些生了孩子的人，在那段时间里他们有医疗补助，他们获得了一点护理机会。然后医疗补助就消失了。所以他们的健康状况就恶化了。所以人们，我在我的诊所里经常看到这种情况。我会看病人几年，
that sidelines them. And this is a very personal thing for me. So I have a brother who struggled with addiction and he's in Pennsylvania and he was able to have Medicaid, which actually paid for his recovery. So at a recovery center, and then also paid for mental health care and paid for therapy and paid for him to see a psychiatrist and
然后我有一两年见不到他们，因为他们失去了保险。然后他们的糖尿病变得非常难以控制。这就像，为什么我们要有这种情况？为什么我们不能有一个系统，让人们在失业时，或者在不得不照顾亲戚时，或者在他们自己患有严重疾病时，能够获得护理？
and now he's been in recovery for about six years and he's had a full-time job that whole time. He has a wonderful girlfriend. He's a taxpaying citizen. But if he hadn't had that Medicaid when he was in his 20s when he was struggling with addiction, he would be dead. And so it's like, but now he's living a really wonderful, full life. And it's like, why don't we want everyone to have that safety net of insurance coverage when they need it to help them like stay healthy, get healthy,
这对我来说是一件非常私人的事情。我有一个兄弟曾与毒瘾作斗争，他在宾夕法尼亚州，他能够获得医疗补助，这实际上支付了他的康复费用。所以在康复中心，也支付了心理健康护理，支付了治疗费用，并支付了他看精神科医生的费用，
and then hopefully one day, you know, get jobs that have employer-sponsored healthcare. But not everyone can do that, but a lot of people can, as long as they have a little bit of help through vulnerable times. Haley, you do some work with people that have caregivers with kids with chronic issues and different things. I wonder from your background and research, if you could tell us some of the statistics about Alabama and anything you want to respond to there?
现在他已经康复了大约六年，这期间他一直有一份全职工作。他有一个很棒的女朋友。他是一个纳税的公民。但如果他在 20 多岁与毒瘾作斗争时没有那份医疗补助，他现在就已经死了。所以这就像，但他现在过着非常美好、充实的生活。这就像，为什么我们不希望每个人在需要时都有那份保险安全网来帮助他们保持健康、恢复健康，
Yeah, yeah. I mean, kind of to bounce off what you were all saying, I mean, our healthcare system is so reactionary versus being proactive and trying to keep people healthy and preventative care is so critical. But often that is not the focus of healthcare. It's, it's when we get to crisis, chronic conditions that are so difficult at some point to be able to manage. And we're having to make tough decisions as providers and support our clients and patients in those decisions when there really are few options.
然后希望有一天，你知道，找到有雇主资助医疗保健的工作。但不是每个人都能做到，但很多人可以，只要他们在脆弱时期得到一点帮助。Hailey，你做一些与有慢性病孩子的护理人员合作的工作，以及其他各种事情。我想从你的背景和研究中，如果你能告诉我们一些关于阿拉巴马州的统计数据，以及你想回应的任何事情？
I know for populations, the populations I work with, the birthing community, Medicaid is huge. The majority of women, a lot of women use and rely on Medicaid. And the Medicaid expansion that took place post-COVID, where they expanded postpartum care for 12 months was really critical. And I think one of the most important things
是的，是的。我的意思是，顺着你们所有人说的话，我的意思是，我们的医疗保健系统是如此反动，而不是主动尝试保持人们的健康，预防性护理是如此关键。但通常这不是医疗保健的重点。它是，当我们陷入危机时，那些在某些时候很难管理的慢性病。作为提供者，我们必须做出艰难的决定，并支持我们的客户和病人在这些决定中，因为确实选择很少。
that they could have done, because statistically we know that women, while they do experience postpartum and can have a lot of physical and mental manifestations, postpartum within six weeks, really we're seeing that women are experiencing the highest rates of postpartum depression and postpartum psychosis and these conditions up to 12 months. So really when you have one six week postpartum visit, you're barely into being a parent coming out of birth and then you're just dropped.
我知道对于群体，我工作的群体，生育社区，医疗补助是巨大的。大多数女性，很多女性使用并依赖医疗补助。新冠疫情后实施的医疗补助扩张，将产后护理延长至 12 个月，这非常关键。我认为这是他们能做的最重要的事情之一，
You don't have care. And so that expansion was really critical to allow women to continue to receive care where we see the majority of postpartum mortality is after maternal mortality is postpartum primarily. And so that was really critical. I wanted to ask about the new Medicaid expansion? Are you familiar with how they're expanding the first 60 days while getting on Medicaid for pregnant women? I was reading about it and that's, I think KIV is about to sign that into law.
因为从统计学上讲，我们知道女性虽然确实会经历产后，并且在六周内可能会有大量的身体和心理表现，但实际上我们看到女性在长达 12 个月的时间里经历着最高比例的产后抑郁症和产后精神病。所以当你只有一次六周的产后检查时，你刚成为父母，刚从分娩中走出来，然后你就被抛弃了。
And so I think that's for, that is for, oh, okay, yeah. So basically kind of making it a lot easier for people to get on Medicaid when they're pregnant and like removing some of those barriers. That's what I understood. I don't take care of pregnant women. So I was like, that sounds good,
你没有护理。所以那次扩张对于让女性继续接受护理非常关键，我们看到大多数产后死亡率主要是产后。所以这非常关键。我想问一下新的医疗补助扩张？你熟悉他们如何为孕妇在获得医疗补助的同时扩大前 60 天吗？我读过关于它的内容，我想 KIV 即将将其签署为法律。
of removing those barriers. But I mean, I have some young patients who do get pregnant, but I'm not an OB-GYN, but it seemed like there were some barriers to signing up for Medicaid when you are pregnant and that Medicaid law was removing those barriers. That was what I understood. Yeah, okay.
所以我认为那是为了，那是为了，哦，好的，是的。所以基本上是让人们在怀孕时更容易获得医疗补助，并消除其中一些障碍。这就是我的理解。我不照顾孕妇。所以我当时想，这听起来不错，
I mean, I think that's how I understand it too. I think, you know, in theory and practice look very different. So I think it sounds, it seems like a good thing and I think that it's gonna be a positive move but it'll be interesting to see how it actually plays out for women because I think that's where it really, we see the impact of these policy decisions trickling down
消除那些障碍。但我的意思是，我有一些怀孕的年轻病人，但我不是妇产科医生，但看起来在怀孕时申请医疗补助确实存在一些障碍，而那项医疗补助法律正在消除这些障碍。这就是我的理解。是的，好的。
directly affecting individuals in the community. I did have a question for you around the Medicaid gap and particularly with your population as far as those individuals as young adults who don't qualify, they they don't make too little to qualify for Medicaid but they make too much, sorry opposite way, they make too much to qualify for Medicaid but they don't make enough to really have like Blue Cross or private plan. What do those individuals do?
我的意思是，我想我也是这样理解的。我认为，你知道，理论和实践看起来非常不同。所以我认为这听起来，这似乎是一件好事，我认为这将是一个积极的举措，但看看它实际上如何为女性发挥作用将会很有趣，因为我认为这就是我们看到这些政策决定向下渗透的地方，
How do they cover their care? Yeah, I mean, sort of a hodgepodge. So essentially if you are a non-disabled adult in Alabama that doesn't have children, you cannot qualify for Medicaid no matter how low your income is. And so, and yeah, so, yeah, I mean, so some of them buy really bad marketplace plans, so which should be outlawed, like one of the big benefits when people said that you lost insurance under Obamacare. It was like, no, it's just not legal to print insurance on a piece of paper and then sell it to people anymore. But there's never really plans that you could eke any care.
直接影响社区中的个人。我确实有一个关于医疗补助缺口的问题，特别是关于你的群体，那些作为年轻人不符合资格的人，他们赚的钱太多了，不符合医疗补助资格，但他们赚的钱又不足以真正拥有蓝十字或私人计划。那些人怎么办？
You could never really milk any blood from that turnip. But those are the plans that got criticized as going away under Obamacare, which a lot of that's been rolled back, unfortunately. Yes, exactly. So actually actually UAB stopped accepting one of those United Health Care junk plans because it was so bad and so if you have that plan all of your appointments at UAB have been cancelled and so they will not like let you step foot in the door. So I have a couple of patients who signed up for that plan unfortunately
他们如何支付他们的护理费用？是的，我的意思是，一种大杂烩。所以本质上，如果你是阿拉巴马州一个没有孩子的非残疾成年人，无论你的收入有多低，你都无法获得医疗补助。所以，是的，我的意思是，所以他们中的一些人购买非常糟糕的市场计划，这应该被取缔，就像当人们说你在奥巴马医改下失去了保险时，最大的好处之一就是，不，在纸上打印保险然后卖给人们是不合法的。但从来没有真正的计划可以让你挤出任何护理。
and so I won't be able to see them at UAB. And so, you know, so yeah, signing up for bad plans. That's one thing people do just being uninsured. You know, that's another thing. So sometimes if you're within Jefferson County, you may be able to access Cooper Green services. If you're outside of Jefferson County at UAB, you can apply for charity care at UAB, which is somewhat onerous and doesn't really cover everything, but at least it's some sort of stopgap. But I would say, you know, a lot of those people are just
你永远无法从那棵芜菁中挤出任何血。但那些是在奥巴马医改下被批评为消失的计划，不幸的是，其中很多已经被撤销了。是的，正是如此。所以实际上 UAB 停止接受其中一种联合健康保险垃圾计划，因为它太糟糕了，所以如果你有那个计划，你在 UAB 的所有预约都被取消了，所以他们不会让你踏进门一步。所以我有一些病人不幸注册了那个计划，
uninsured. And so those are the people I see at Equal Access Birmingham, which is like our student run free health clinic. And, you know, and it's good. There we can see a lot of patients who have, you know, high blood pressure, diabetes, and generally can manage it fairly well. UAB has another clinic called the Path Clinic for patients with diabetes, where they can get free medications if they're uninsured and they have poorly controlled diabetes. So there's some of these options, but for instance, at the free health clinic, we can't do any cancer screening. So it's like talking about preventive healthcare, none of those are covered.
所以我将无法在 UAB 见到他们。所以，你知道，所以是的，注册糟糕的计划。这是人们做的一件事，只是没有保险。你知道，这是另一件事。所以有时如果你在杰斐逊县内，你可能能够获得 Cooper Green 服务。如果你在杰斐逊县外，在 UAB，你可以申请 UAB 的慈善护理，这有点繁琐，而且并不能真正覆盖所有东西，但至少它是一种权宜之计。但我会说，你知道，很多人只是
We can see you, check your blood pressure, check your blood sugar, give you some medications for free and not, we don't have like a comprehensive formulary, but yeah, so it's like, no, it's not a good situation. So you can maybe cobble together some sort of plan, but it's not optimal and that's what happened. So, and I have appreciated getting to see these patients who are uninsured or underinsured at the free clinic
没有保险。所以这些人就是我在 Equal Access Birmingham 看到的，这是我们学生经营的免费健康诊所。而且，你知道，这很好。在那里我们可以看到很多患有高血压、糖尿病的病人，通常可以管理得相当好。 UAB 有另一个名为 Path Clinic 的诊所，专门为糖尿病患者服务，如果他们没有保险且糖尿病控制不佳，他们可以在那里获得免费药物。所以有一些这样的选择，但例如，在免费健康诊所，我们不能做任何癌症筛查。所以这就像谈论预防性医疗保健，这些都不在覆盖范围内。
because I really then see a lot of the barriers. And a lot, almost all the patients I see at the free health clinic work. There are so few who don't work, but a lot of them are doing things that are landscaping or working in service industries like restaurants or just working part-time because they're caring for an aging parent or something like that. So I would say it would be interesting to know the statistics.
我们可以看你，检查你的血压，检查你的血糖，给你一些免费的药物，我们没有像全面的处方集，但是的，所以这就像，不，这不是一个好的情况。所以你也许可以拼凑出某种计划，但它不是最优的，这就是发生的事情。所以，而且我很感激能在免费诊所见到这些没有保险或保险不足的病人，
I don't know them, but I would say just anecdotally, most of these people are working that I see at the free clinic and yet they still don't have access to insurance. Well, and a lot of, you know, I can hear like, the comments on this already about, you know, well, who's going to pay for it or whatever. And the thing is, you know, there is in medicine, hard decisions, you know, that I don't know that I'm equipped to solve, you know If somebody's getting close to the end of life and they're already, you know 85 and they need a million dollars of care or something You know what? Those are hard questions. A lot of these questions aren't hard. I mean you mentioned I've been all in the beginning It's not like it helps anybody It's not like it even saves that money that much money
因为我确实看到了很多障碍。而且，我在免费健康诊所看到的几乎所有病人都工作。很少有人不工作，但他们中的很多人在做园艺工作，或者在服务行业（如餐馆）工作，或者只是兼职工作，因为他们在照顾年迈的父母之类的。所以我认为知道统计数据会很有趣。
Like there's not a reason to do any of this stuff. And in most cases, it's more expensive for the state. So the people saying like, well, who's gonna pay for it? You will put you will you will pay less, we will give you money. Just listen, you know, get a QT. The like a buterol is, you know, an asthma man. It's an animal axis man. No one is is like, well, yeah, a lot of free healthcare. Let me go to the buffet and it's been a long weekend and let me, you know, like what is the reason
我不知道，但我会说，根据轶事，我在免费诊所看到的大多数人都在工作，但他们仍然无法获得保险。嗯，而且很多，你知道，我已经可以听到关于这个的评论了，关于，嗯，谁来支付它之类的。事实是，你知道，在医学中，有艰难的决定，你知道，我不知道我是否有能力解决，你知道，如果有人接近生命尽头，他们已经 85 岁了，他们需要一百万美元的护理之类的。你知道吗？那些是难题。很多这些问题并不难。我的意思是，你提到了我一开始说的，它不像它能帮助任何人，它甚至不像它能节省那么多钱。
to withhold this thing that is old as dirt, generic, cheap to make, and a emergency life saving med that is not abusable, you know, like has a long expiration? Like what is the reason? Why do that other than just you have the power to do it and you want to see what we can get away with? And I mean, the who's paying for it question is really interesting. You're exactly right. You are. So I mean, the taxpayers of Jefferson County are funding Cooper Green. You know, UAB is passing costs along to you when it gives a lot of care away for free, charity care.
就像没有理由做这些事情一样。在大多数情况下，这对州来说更昂贵。所以那些说“嗯，谁来支付它？”的人，你们会支付，你们会支付更少，我们会给你们钱。只要听着，你知道，得到一个 QT。沙丁胺醇是一种哮喘药。它是一种过敏药。没有人会说，嗯，是的，大量的免费医疗。让我去自助餐，这是一个漫长的周末，让我，你知道，什么理由
So, and that's very complicated because it's a tax, you know, it's a nonprofit and that's very complicated. The nonprofit of UHSF that is fully designed to help the for-profit of UAB make money. Right. Yeah, so it's not like- It's illegal, it's not, they're not doing anything wrong.
扣留这种像泥土一样古老、通用、制造便宜、且不过期的紧急救命药？就像什么理由？为什么要这样做，除了你拥有权力这样做，并且你想看看我们能逃脱什么？而且我的意思是，谁来支付这个问题真的很有趣。你是完全正确的。你是。所以我的意思是，杰斐逊县的纳税人在资助 Cooper Green。你知道，当 UAB 免费提供大量护理、慈善护理时，它正在将成本转嫁给你。
Yeah, I can't, you know, I don't know what to really say about that. But yeah, the answer like is more preventive care. And I just, you know, because it's like, if you don't care for that person's type one diabetes, they're gonna need a kidney transplant in 10 years. So what's gonna happen is they have kidney failure because of their type one diabetes, then they go on dialysis. And so then they go on dialysis. And so then they automatically qualify for Medicare. So then you as a taxpayer are paying for that. And then hopefully they can get off of their dialysis
所以，这非常复杂，因为它是一种税，你知道，它是一个非营利组织，这非常复杂。 UHSF 的非营利组织完全是为了帮助 UAB 的营利组织赚钱。对。是的，所以它不像——这是非法的，它不是，他们没有做错任何事。
and get a transplant, at which point then they stop qualifying for Medicare and Medicaid because they're no longer disabled by being on dialysis. And then hopefully they can keep their transplant through some means, but it is, it's, it's really messed up. And I'd like other states have seen so much benefit from Medicaid expansion. I was really excited last year when our state lawmakers heard from North Carolina and Arkansas
是的，我不能，你知道，我不知道该怎么说。但是的，答案就像是更多的预防性护理。而且我只是，你知道，因为它就像，如果你不照顾那个人的 1 型糖尿病，他们 10 年后就需要肾移植。所以会发生什么，他们因为 1 型糖尿病而肾衰竭，然后他们进行透析。所以然后他们进行透析。所以然后他们自动获得医疗保险（Medicare）资格。所以然后你作为纳税人在支付费用。然后希望他们能停止透析，
about the successes of expansion in those states. And like, they were like, yes, it's wonderful. It's saving rural hospitals. It's like saving lives. Like there was one congressman from North Carolina, a Republican congressman from a rural district who basically said, I was against this. But as soon as it passed, I had all my constituents coming up to me thanking me and saying, I had a relative.
并获得移植，届时他们就不再符合医疗保险和医疗补助资格，因为他们不再因为透析而残疾。然后希望他们能通过某种方式保留他们的移植，但这，这真的很糟糕。而且我希望其他州已经从医疗补助扩张中看到了很多好处。去年当我们的州议员听到北卡罗来纳州和阿肯色州关于这些州扩张的成功时，我真的很兴奋。而且就像，他们说，是的，这太棒了。它正在拯救农村医院。它就像在拯救生命。就像北卡罗来纳州有一位国会议员，一位来自农村选区的共和党国会议员，他基本上说，我反对这个。但一旦它通过，我所有的选民都来感谢我，说，我有一个亲戚。
I had a friend who benefited from this. And so his mind had been changed. And earlier this year before the presidential election, Blue Cross was coming in saying like, hey, we might be able to do a partnership with you, a public private partnership, like essentially what all kids says and do that for adults, which is what was done in Arkansas.
我有一个朋友从中受益。所以他的想法改变了。而在总统选举前的今年早些时候，蓝十字公司进来说，嘿，我们也许能和你建立伙伴关系，一种公私伙伴关系，本质上就像所有孩子所做的那样，并为成年人这样做，这就是阿肯色州所做的。
And so it was like, there was hope when there was still kind of thoughts that there would be federal dollars coming in if Medicaid expansion occurred. And now that that's in question because of federal funding cuts in the budget, I think that that's not gonna be politically tenable, but it was really exciting
所以就像，当人们仍然认为如果医疗补助扩张发生，会有联邦资金进来时，是有希望的。而现在因为预算中的联邦资金削减，这受到了质疑，我认为这在政治上是站不住脚的，但这真的很令人兴奋，
that there was actually some hope because I think, you know, I just so many, like I, there's just too many stories to count of people who would be positively impacted by this that I see literally every day. Well, and so before I did private practice, I was with UAV React, which is an assertive community treatment team. And we take and talking to the viewer too, even if you guys know what these are, but they take some of the worst cases of psychotic mental illness that are very expensive. And one of the reasons why Medicaid pays more for that, a lot of those patients have been in Bryce multiple times.
实际上有一些希望，因为我认为，你知道，我只是，有太多的故事无法计数，关于那些会受到积极影响的人，我每天都能看到。嗯，所以在做私人诊所之前，我在 UAV React，这是一个果断的社区治疗团队。我们采取，即使你们知道这些是什么，但他们采取一些非常昂贵的精神病精神疾病的最坏病例。医疗补助为这些支付更多费用的原因之一，很多这些病人都多次去过 Bryce。
You usually have a severe mental illness, but also comorbid with something else like an addiction or a personality disorder. And it really takes a lot to be on that team. They don't just take anybody. And a lot of the time patients that have schizophrenia or addiction or something, they're going to the ER a lot. And then that's really expensive.
你通常有严重的精神疾病，但也伴有其他疾病，如毒瘾或人格障碍。要加入那个团队真的需要很多。他们不仅仅接受任何人。而且很多时候患有精神分裂症或毒瘾的人，他们经常去急诊室。然后那真的很贵。
So assertive community treatment teams with this model to bring down the cost, because if we can pay a little bit of a stipend for apartment and show somebody how to get on SSDI so that they can pay for the apartment and some of the, and then just have medication and become stable, they become cheaper because if they're homeless, there's court costs,
所以果断的社区治疗团队用这种模式来降低成本，因为如果我们能为公寓支付一点津贴，并向某人展示如何获得 SSDI，这样他们就可以支付公寓和一些，然后只要有药物并变得稳定，他们就会变得更便宜，因为如果他们无家可归，就会有法庭费用，
there's law enforcement costs, there's property values going down, there's panhandling, there's maybe crime, there's all of these things. Not accounting for any of that, the team had been around a while and a couple of years before I was on it there was a doctor who
会有执法成本，会有房产价值下降，会有乞讨，可能会有犯罪，会有所有这些事情。没有考虑到任何这些，团队已经存在了一段时间，在我加入的前几年，有一位医生
was from New York and was doing some research paper and asked if they could got permission from UAB to go through the data and The you know a team like that has a couple social workers, which I mean, I know don't make much Because I was on it, you know nurses and Psychiatrists, so they're not terribly expensive. It's about, depending on how their staff, 12 to 15 people, they can see about 13 people per person on that team per year. And the doctor went and looked at all of it and was like, you guys are saving just in Medicaid,
来自纽约，正在做一些研究论文，并询问他们是否获得了 UAB 的许可来查看数据。你知道，像这样的团队有几个社会工作者，我的意思是，我知道他们赚的不多，因为我在里面，你知道，护士和精神科医生，所以他们并不太贵。这取决于他们的人员配置，12 到 15 人，他们每年可以看大约 13 人。医生去看了所有这些，就像，你们在医疗补助方面节省了，
because you could go through the data, like about a million dollars per person for the state. So for the $30,000 you pay me, you know, you get $34,000. You make, you're getting, and I could see five to seven people, you're essentially saving five to seven million dollars. I mean, that investment is unreal. I mean, to pay $34,000 and save five to seven million, and you've got two of these teams in the state and you're fighting to shut them down. And you're saying like, well, why are all these social workers, whatever? Why is it the basic economics people that pretend that this is about money? It clearly is not about
因为你可以查看数据，大约每人一百万美元。所以对于你支付给我的 30,000 美元，你知道，你得到 34,000 美元。你赚，你正在得到，我可以看五到七个人，你本质上节省了五到七百万美元。我的意思是，那项投资是不真实的。我的意思是，支付 34,000 美元并节省五到七百万，而且你在州里有两个这样的团队，你正在努力关闭它们。而且你说，嗯，为什么所有这些社会工作者，无论如何？为什么是那些假装这是关于钱的基本经济学人？这显然不是关于
money. You know, 100% so I actually I have several react patients in my clinic, I just saw one on Friday. And she is so sweet, but has had a lot of abuse and abuse of head trauma and has mental illness and intellectual disability and you know prior to being on React was in the ED all the time just like with a little complaints but you know like when you don't have any education or you're worried about your body you go to the emergency room because you're scared and so and now she hasn't been to the emergency room
钱。你知道，100% 所以我实际上，我的诊所里有几个 React 病人，我周五刚见过一个。她很甜，但遭受了很多虐待和虐待性头部创伤，患有精神疾病和智力障碍，你知道在加入 React 之前，一直都在急诊室，就像有一些小抱怨，但你知道，当你没有任何教育或者你担心你的身体时，你会去急诊室，因为你害怕，所以现在她已经几年没有去过急诊室了，
in like years and she like, she comes to see me often. She has some pain, but we got her set up with aquatic physical therapy and her workers make sure she gets to that and she's feeling so much better, doing a lot of healthy habits and like, she's just like thriving. And I see that in a lot of my React patients,
她经常来看我。她有一些疼痛，但我们让她进行了水上物理治疗，她的工作人员确保她能去那里，她感觉好多了，做了很多健康的习惯，而且就像，她只是在茁壮成长。我在我的很多 React 病人身上都看到了这一点，
like they, the React program is wonderful. And you're exactly right. It's not about saving money because we know preventive care and things like that save money. It's about, I don't know what it's about. I think it's sometimes about racism, sometimes about who deserves things
就像他们，React 项目太棒了。而且你是完全正确的。这不是关于省钱，因为我们知道预防性护理之类的事情可以省钱。这是关于，我不知道这是关于什么。我认为有时是关于种族主义，有时是关于谁在我们的州、我们的社会中值得拥有这些东西。
in our state, in our society. Well, no one has enough. And as you cut these benefits and you create a crisis, I mean, people, I think, get angry enough that they're like, well, fine, I'm just gonna blow the whole thing up. And that's what you're doing when you can take more and more preventative gateways away and you force the whole system into crisis,
嗯，没有人有足够的。当你削减这些福利并制造危机时，我的意思是，人们，我认为变得足够愤怒，以至于他们说，好吧，没关系，我只是要炸掉整个事情。这就是当你能拿走越来越多的预防性门户，并强迫整个系统陷入危机时你所做的事情，
you put everything on emergency care. And emergency care is incredibly expensive and also not designed to treat things like dialysis and diabetes medication and just everything preventative cholesterol, you know. Yeah, it's so wild because it, you know, in so many social issues there isn't the infrastructure, there aren't, there isn't the evidence-based, you know, research that says these care teams are impactful, but in medicine, we know a lot of that works. We've seen it work. We've seen it work in other states.
你把一切都放在紧急护理上。而紧急护理极其昂贵，而且也不是为了治疗透析和糖尿病药物以及所有预防性胆固醇之类的东西而设计的。是的，这太疯狂了，因为它，你知道，在这么多社会问题中，没有基础设施，没有基于证据的，你知道，研究说这些护理团队是有影响力的，但在医学中，我们知道很多那是有效的。我们已经看到它有效。我们已经看到它在其他州有效。
We know that it can be beneficial, and yet we still cannot move the needle forward in trying to help individuals, politicians, look and understand that these measures, if we're treating them upfront, is going to reduce costs, going to reduce workload, going to reduce trauma. I mean, I think about the medical trauma that these patients experience, you know, just to stay with the example of the albuterol, If you have a client patient who uses albuterol and gets that treatment upfront and it gets that support,
我们知道它可能是有益的，然而我们仍然无法在试图帮助个人、政治家、审视和理解这些措施方面推动针头前进，如果我们预先治疗它们，将会降低成本，降低工作量，降低创伤。我的意思是，我想到这些病人经历的医疗创伤，你知道，就拿沙丁胺醇的例子来说，如果你有一个使用沙丁胺醇并预先获得该治疗并获得该支持的客户病人，
they're not having to interface with the medical system as much versus what you were saying, they're not getting what they need. And so now they're having to have chronic conditions managed and going to the hospital and the ER and the medical trauma that those individuals experience, as well as your medical teams, your medical professionals, because they are put into Christ
他们不必像你所说的那样与医疗系统进行那么多的交互，他们没有得到他们需要的。所以现在他们不得不管理慢性病，去医院和急诊室，以及那些个人经历的医疗创伤，还有你的医疗团队，你的医疗专业人员，因为他们被置于危机中，
like everything's on fire all the time. You know, it's hurry, hurry, hurry, fix this. But it's like, you know, you can't put a bandaid on a bullet wound. So I mean, I think those things are important to think about as well. Dr. Eganard, could you speak a little bit to, because you're talking, we're talking about some issues with private insurance and some issues with Medicaid, and they're both important, and people may not know how that works,
就像一切都在着火。你知道，这是快，快，快，修复这个。但就像，你知道，你不能在弹孔上贴创可贴。所以我的意思是，我认为这些事情也值得思考。Eganard 博士，你能谈谈吗，因为你在谈论，我们正在谈论私人保险的一些问题和医疗补助的一些问题，它们都很重要，人们可能不知道它是如何运作的，
but there are, and there's some overlap in that. You know, like the Medicaid expansion you're talking about, it's kind of like saving for retirement. Like you pay money into it and your employer matches you. Alabama is leaving a lot of money on the table by not investing in these things because they get the money back. And then the relationship between, I think a lot of people think Medicaid just does its own thing and then private insurance is over here, which isn't really true. Medicaid is going to be kind of the gold standard of like how to chart and the way the system is thinking and then
但有，而且其中有一些重叠。你知道，就像你谈到的医疗补助扩张，它有点像为退休储蓄。就像你付钱进去，你的雇主匹配你。阿拉巴马州因为不投资这些事情而留下了很多钱，因为他们拿回了钱。然后关系，我认为很多人认为医疗补助只是做它自己的事情，然后私人保险在这里，这并不是真的。医疗补助将成为某种黄金标准，关于如何记录以及系统思考的方式，然后
Insurance is going to reflect that I mean our practice has to try and predict what's going to happen because it means that we need to change the way that we do things and You to do that you look at what did Medicaid do now? What is Blue Cross federal doing in DC and then you know that the plans that are the state Blue Cross plans are going to be a reflection of that eventually. And insurance just says all the time, we're going to do this, this is a new policy, everybody, you know, and things that are like really life-changing and then most of them don't happen. But one of the best ways to kind of predict what an insurance company will do is look where Medicaid's going. And could you talk a little bit about the economics of that for people that may not be familiar?
保险业会反映出这一点，我的意思是，我们的业务必须尝试预测将会发生什么，因为这意味着我们需要改变做事方式。要做到这一点，你得看看医疗补助计划（Medicaid）现在在做什么？华盛顿特区的联邦蓝十字（Blue Cross）在做什么？然后你就知道，各州的蓝十字计划最终会反映出这些变化。保险公司总是说：“我们要这样做，这是一项新政策，大家请注意。”有些事情确实会改变生活，但大多数都没有发生。不过，预测保险公司行为的最好方法之一，就是观察医疗补助计划的发展方向。你能为那些不太熟悉的人谈谈其中的经济学原理吗？
Yeah, and so I guess I think private insurance look at Medicaid but also Medicare. And so, you know, Medicaid is governmental insurance for low income and disabled people. And mostly in Alabama, it's for disabled adults adults and that is who qualifies for Medicaid and then Medicare obviously for people some people who have who are disabled can qualify for Medicare and so can get Medicare before the age of 65 that's a little complicated but but for most people it's people who get you know insurance after 65 and then for some qualifying conditions I mentioned, if you go on dialysis, you qualify for Medicare.
是的，我想私人保险公司会关注医疗补助计划，也会关注联邦医疗保险（Medicare）。医疗补助计划是政府为低收入和残疾人提供的保险。在阿拉巴马州，它主要针对残疾成年人，这就是有资格获得医疗补助的人群。显然，联邦医疗保险是针对某些残疾人的，所以有些人不到65岁也能获得联邦医疗保险，这有点复杂。但对大多数人来说，它是为65岁以上的人提供的保险。此外，对于我提到的某些符合条件的疾病，比如如果你需要透析，你就有资格获得联邦医疗保险。
But yeah, so Medicare and Medicaid and the Centers for Medicaid Services and CMS, they do set a lot of policy precedents for what medications are going to be paid for. And yeah, private insurers definitely look to those. And so, you know, private insurers, I think sometimes people are like, I have Blue Cross. And it's like, oh, gosh, what does that mean? Like, you know, because the state employee Blue Cross is different from federal Blue
是的，联邦医疗保险、医疗补助计划以及医疗保险和医疗补助服务中心（CMS）确实为哪些药物可以报销设定了许多政策先例。私人保险公司肯定会参考这些。有时人们会说：“我有蓝十字保险。”这让人很困惑，因为州雇员的蓝十字计划与联邦蓝十字计划是不同的，
Cross is different from specific employer plans that are contracted with Blue Cross. And so I think patients don't understand that there's a lot of diversity within employer-sponsored plans and within private insurance plans. But yeah, they do look to Medicaid and Medicare to see sort of coverage. And like I said before, Medicaid actually has pretty good prescription drug coverage for a wide variety of conditions.
与蓝十字签约的特定雇主计划也不同。我认为患者并不了解雇主资助的计划和私人保险计划内部存在很大的差异。但确实，他们会参考医疗补助和联邦医疗保险来确定承保范围。正如我之前所说，医疗补助计划实际上对多种疾病都有相当不错的处方药承保范围。
So I rarely have it be the case that I wanna prescribe something to a patient with Medicaid that they're not going to cover it. So prescription drug coverage is pretty good. There are some things that they don't pay for, like they don't pay for home health. So Medicaid doesn't pay for home health, which is really a challenge if you have a patient
所以我很少遇到想给医疗补助计划的患者开药却无法报销的情况。因此，处方药的承保范围相当不错。有些东西他们不支付，比如家庭护理。医疗补助不支付家庭护理费用，如果你有一位
who needs an in-home health service. And so there's definitely some limitations. There's also limitations for who accepts Medicaid. So a lot of, we have a lot of struggles getting patients in for physical therapy and occupational therapy because that only like hospital associated practices will see patients with Medicaid for those services. And so there's challenges with Medicaid,
需要居家护理服务的患者，这确实是一个挑战。所以肯定存在一些局限性。在接受医疗补助的机构方面也有限制。我们很难让患者预约到物理治疗和职业治疗，因为只有与医院相关的诊所才会为这些服务接收医疗补助患者。所以医疗补助确实存在挑战，
but overall it's pretty good. I think private insurance actually tends to be more of the issue when we're thinking about drug coverage, which I think is the thing that impacts most patients is drug affordability and cost and things. And so those companies are trying to save money. And so they have a big incentive to deny a lot of medications. And so it was a private company who required a prior authorization for albuterol.
但总体来说还不错。我认为在考虑药物承保时，私人保险往往才是更大的问题。我认为最影响患者的是药物的可负担性、成本等问题。这些公司试图省钱，因此他们有很大的动力去拒绝报销许多药物。曾有一家私人公司要求对沙丁胺醇进行事先授权。
And so those companies are, yeah, very much trying to save money, trying to cut costs. They're also, I think, trying to make it difficult for patients and physicians so that they just give up. So like, you could maybe get this covered, but it's so onerous to get it covered that you're just gonna give up. So yeah, you could maybe get this covered, but it's so onerous to get it covered that you're just gonna give up. Oh yeah, so I don't really see that with Medicaid,
这些公司确实非常想省钱，试图削减成本。我认为他们还试图让患者和医生感到困难，这样他们就会放弃。比如，你也许能获得报销，但过程极其繁琐，以至于你最终会放弃。是的，你也许能获得报销，但过程极其繁琐，以至于你最终会放弃。哦，是的，我在医疗补助计划中真的没见过这种情况，
which is nice. It's pretty clear what's covered with Medicaid too. So there's a list called a formula that you can look at and see if it's gonna be covered, if it is, if it's gonna require prior authorization, where there's nothing like that for private insurers. So you kind of have to guess, you're like, I hope this is covered, it may be covered.
这很好。医疗补助计划的承保范围也很明确。有一份名为“处方集”的清单，你可以查看某种药是否在承保范围内，如果承保，是否需要事先授权。而私人保险公司根本没有这样的东西。所以你只能猜测，心想：“希望这药在承保范围内，也许吧。”
And then you prescribe it and then it's like, oh no, it's not covered. And then it's like, well, what is covered? And then like, well, you don't know, your patient's gonna have to call the insurance company and ask them what's covered for all this. And then it's, they still don't tell you. I mean, that's every time they put enough bureaucracy
然后你开了药，结果发现：“哦，不，不在承保范围内。”然后你会问：“那什么在承保范围内？”对方回答：“不知道，你的患者得打电话给保险公司问问。”即便如此，他们还是不告诉你。我的意思是，每次他们在你和你想要的东西之间设置足够的官僚障碍，
in front of you and what you want, then there's less people that are gonna complete it and then there's more money that they get to keep. And so, in a lot of what you're talking about, I mean, I went through with my doctor, like you've got seven medications, you have no idea which one they cover, but it took you three weeks to figure out
完成的人就会变少，他们能省下的钱就越多。你谈到的很多情况，我跟我医生经历过，我有七种药，你根本不知道他们报销哪一种，但花了三个星期才弄清楚
after three referrals that they weren't gonna cover this one. So, three times seven, is that how many weeks you need of the doctor's time to try and, I mean, I luckily had a doctor that was willing to work with me and you know, wanted to fight with the insurance company. But, I mean, we see a lot of people at our practice saying they want to leave healthcare because of the amount of paperwork. And the amount of paperwork, I mean, I think over documentation and bureaucracies is a thing that medics and has always kind of leaned into. medicine has always kind of leaned into, but most of the growth in paperwork, just the explosion in documentation that is getting doctors burned out and leaving the profession comes from private insurance companies recently.
经过三次转诊后，他们不报销这一种。所以，3乘以7，你需要医生花多少周的时间去尝试？幸运的是，我的医生愿意配合我，想要与保险公司抗争。但是，我们在诊所看到很多人说因为文书工作太多而想离开医疗行业。文书工作量，我认为过度记录和官僚主义是医学界一直存在的问题，但最近文书工作的增长，也就是导致医生精疲力竭并离开该行业的记录爆炸，主要来自私人保险公司。
Yes, yeah, and 100% does. And it's just like, it's so frustrating for everyone. And it's just a really impedes care. And, and I mean, it's like, why aren't all generic medicines just covered? You know, they're cheap. Like, why should I ever have to do a prior authorization for a blood pressure medicine that was approved in like 1988? You know, it's like, this has been around. It's good. It's like, it's why?
是的，百分之百是这样。这对每个人来说都太令人沮丧了，而且它确实阻碍了护理。我的意思是，为什么所有的仿制药不能直接报销？它们很便宜。为什么我还要为一种1988年就获批的降压药做事先授权？这药已经存在很久了，效果很好，为什么？
Like, I don't know. It's, there's no rationale. And it has to do, I know with like the contracts that private insurers have with drug companies. And there's a lot of complexity there, too. But it's just there's no reason why health care companies should be billion-dollar businesses and be paying their executives tens of millions of dollars when they won't cover like a generic blood pressure
我不知道，这根本没有道理。我知道这与私人保险公司和制药公司之间的合同有关。其中有很多复杂性。但医疗保健公司不应该成为价值数十亿美元的企业，在不报销仿制降压药的情况下，还给高管支付数千万美元的薪水。
medicine or they will cover it but you have to do a lot of paperwork and have a phone call with you know with a peer-to-peer you know to talk about it it's it's it's really sad and and sometimes I just want like my patients to shadow me and like be like come and like see and like most of my patients are sweet and they're like understanding and I communicate with them, but I just want everyone to come in shadow and just be, this is what it's like. We're trying to do our best. I think most doctors are really trying to do their best to take care of patients and to fight for patients, but it is hard to have the energy to do it every day. Well, and if you're requiring prior authorizations or referrals for things that seem unrelated, you know, like if somebody has a sexual assault and
或者他们虽然报销，但你必须做大量的文书工作，还要和同行进行电话沟通来讨论这个问题，这真的很可悲。有时我真想让我的患者跟着我，看看我的工作。我的大多数患者都很贴心，他们很理解我，我也和他们沟通，但我只是想让每个人都来看看，这就是我们的处境。我认为大多数医生都在尽最大努力照顾患者并为患者争取权益，但每天都要保持这种精力真的很难。好吧，如果你对看起来不相关的事情要求事先授权或转诊，比如如果某人遭受了性侵犯，
they want to go to therapy, why does the insurance company tell them that they have to go get their cholesterol checked first and wait six months when we know that the faster you get care for trauma, the cheaper it is for the insurance company to treat, you know, because the faster you get better. You make a trauma sip for seven months so that I can go see my primary care doctor to get a referral to go to therapy. That means that trauma has festered
他们想去接受心理治疗，为什么保险公司告诉他们必须先去检查胆固醇，还要等六个月？我们都知道，创伤治疗越及时，保险公司的治疗成本就越低，因为患者康复得越快。你让创伤发酵七个月，好让我去看初级保健医生，拿到转诊单去接受治疗。这意味着创伤已经恶化，
and is statistically gonna do more damage to your life and neurobiology. Yeah, 100%. And there was just a law passed in Alabama that you can see a physical therapist without a referral, which is awesome. And but then like practically, some insurers are still saying no, you actually need a referral. And it's like, well, this is a law thing, you don't need a referral. And like, you know, if you like, tweak your knee while playing basketball, like, it's okay, just go see a physical therapist. And if they, you know, if they're like, Oh, this isn't getting better, like, go and see your doctor. And then like, maybe you need some imaging or whatever. But it's like, the same with it should be the same way for therapy as well. Like if you know, something bad happens to you, you know, a death or a job loss, like, you know, that you just want to maybe talk about it and seek therapy. And why can't you go and do that directly? It's crazy.
从统计学上讲，会对你的生活和神经生物学造成更大的损害。是的，百分之百。阿拉巴马州刚刚通过了一项法律，你可以无需转诊就去看物理治疗师，这太棒了。但实际上，一些保险公司仍然说不行，你确实需要转诊。这就像是，法律规定不需要转诊。如果你打篮球时扭伤了膝盖，没关系，直接去看物理治疗师就行了。如果他们说：“哦，这没好转，去看看你的医生。”然后你可能需要做影像检查什么的。但对于心理治疗也应该是一样的。如果发生了不好的事情，比如亲人去世或失业，你只是想谈谈并寻求心理治疗，为什么不能直接去呢？这太疯狂了。
Like, you know, therapy is not a harmful intervention. It's not like we're saying like patients should be able to go and buy like fentanyl at the pharmacy. You know, like it's not a harmful intervention to like get therapy, you know, it's just crazy. Yeah, it's not an abusable addictive. Yeah. I mean, it's so clear, it's so evident
心理治疗不是一种有害的干预措施。我们并不是说患者应该能够去药店买芬太尼。接受心理治疗并不是一种有害的干预措施，这太疯狂了。是的，它不是一种容易滥用成瘾的东西。我的意思是，这很明显，
that it's such a predatory model, particularly for low-income individuals. Because you think about just all these phone calls and conversations and points of contact, that's if you have the time around your two or three jobs or four jobs that you're working and how much mental capacity do you have for that? Are you a parent?
这是一种掠夺性模式，特别是对低收入个人而言。因为你想想所有这些电话、对话和联系点，如果你在做两三份甚至四份工作，你哪有时间处理这些？你的心理承受能力有多少？你是家长吗？
Do you have other responsibilities? I mean, most people can't just sit on the phone all day and try to get this $4 prescription cover that would be life changing for them. I think it's just it's set up for people to fail and to give up, you know, and it's just, it doesn't need to be that way. No, it doesn't.
你有其他责任吗？大多数人不可能整天坐在电话旁，试图为那张能改变他们生活的4美元处方寻求报销。我认为这简直就是为了让人失败和放弃而设置的，这根本没必要。是的，确实没必要。
Yeah, it's, yeah, really at every turn, it feels very broken. I think like why I'm such an advocate for Medicaid expansion is that like, it makes things better for people. And I just see it so clearly when people are able to get on reliable insurance and get that primary care and get their chronic conditions treated. It's an intervention that is so impactful.
是的，每一步都让人感觉这个系统已经彻底崩溃了。我认为我之所以如此支持医疗补助扩张，是因为它确实让人们的生活变得更好。当人们能够获得可靠的保险、获得初级保健并治疗慢性病时，我能非常清楚地看到这一点。这是一种非常有影响力的干预措施。
And it's not perfect. Like I said, Medicaid doesn't cover everything. But it's so much better than nothing, you know, where patients are using the ED or not or getting really sick. And so it's such, like, I don't know how to fix private insurers. Like, I think that needs to be, there needs to be massive reform there.
它并不完美。正如我所说，医疗补助并不覆盖所有东西。但它比什么都没有要好得多，否则患者只能去急诊室，或者病情变得非常严重。所以，我不知道该如何修复私人保险公司，我认为那里需要进行大规模的改革。
So, and I don't know how to do that, but I do know from my own personal experience and then also from all the data from other states with Medicaid expansion, it does good stuff. It saves rural hospitals, it saves lives, it saves money. It's all the good stuff. So from the economics people, we know it saves money. And then for the bleeding heart people,
我不知道该怎么做，但我从自己的个人经验以及其他州医疗补助扩张的数据中知道，它确实有好处。它拯救了农村医院，拯救了生命，节省了资金。全是好事。所以从经济学角度来看，我们知道它能省钱。而对于那些富有同情心的人来说，
we know it saves lives. So it should be something that we're all on the same page for. Well, and the people that moves the needle on so many secondary issues that the people who claim that it's about money claim to care about, like a highly qualified workforce, like encouraging people to work because they actually, if you can't afford a car, an apartment and insurance in because they actually, you know, if you can't, if you don't can't afford a car and apartment and insurance in America, why would you work, you know, you kind of need those things to function. And then property values. I mean, what, what do you want to look at what the differences and states
我们知道它能拯救生命。所以这应该是我们所有人都能达成共识的事情。而且，它在许多次要问题上起到了关键作用，而那些声称关心金钱的人所关心的，比如高素质的劳动力，比如鼓励人们工作，因为如果你在美国买不起车、租不起房、买不起保险，你为什么要工作呢？你需要这些东西才能正常生活。还有房产价值。你想看看那些
where, you know, Medicaid is there and the amount of people that move there and invest in those places? I mean, these things matter. And this is basic economics. So don't say that and then advocate with these things when you can't look at a pie chart. It's objective data. We have it. It's not an opinion. No, and it's hard because it's like, we want and need people to work low wage jobs. Like you want your people to work at McDonald's or work at a gas station or work at these places because as a consumer, you want to have those things. You want to be able to get gas and not wait in line. You don't want to wait in line at fast food, all that kind of those things. But most of those employees aren't given full-time schedules that would entitle them to health insurance. And so it's like, if you want society to function as it's functioning,
有医疗补助的州与没有的州之间的差异，以及搬到那里并投资的人数吗？这些都很重要。这是基本的经济学。所以，如果你连饼图都看不懂，就别说那些话，也别用这些理由来辩护。这是客观数据，不是观点。不，这很难，因为我们想要也需要人们从事低薪工作。你希望人们在麦当劳、加油站或这些地方工作，因为作为消费者，你想要这些服务。你想要加油时不排队，不想在快餐店排队，诸如此类。但大多数员工并没有获得能让他们享受医疗保险的全职时间表。所以，如果你希望社会正常运转，
you should want those people to be able to work there and yet still stay healthy. It's a win-win. It just comes back to the fallacy that poor people don't work hard, so therefore don't deserve anything. I think that that's just a core misunderstanding that a lot of people have, or they think, I've worked really hard to get what I have, other people can do the same thing. And it's just that classic mentality that I think was ushered in the Reagan era and like really has been really sticky and hard to debunk. Well, I think that like there's this idea that... One second, sorry.
你应该希望这些人能够在那里工作的同时保持健康。这是一个双赢的局面。这归根结底是一个谬论，即穷人不努力工作，所以不配得到任何东西。我认为这是许多人核心的误解，或者他们认为：“我努力工作才有了今天，别人也能做到。”这是一种经典的思维方式，我认为是在里根时代引入的，而且非常顽固，很难反驳。好吧，我认为有一种想法是……等一下，抱歉。
I'm losing my train of thought. I apologize. I need to cut you off. It'll come back to me. Hopefully I can cut this. I remember, yeah. So I remember like in the 90s all the way back then, like that people were talking about the cost of healthcare getting to this point where it would just not be sustainable and that it would be not be sustainable and that it would be the big corporations that would say, we want a public option or we want more regulation on insurance. It's something that kind of count because the pendulum couldn't swing so far the other way that there would have to be some way where the federal government was getting more involved
我思路断了。我很抱歉。我得打断你一下。我会想起来的。希望我能剪掉这段。我想起来了。我记得在90年代，人们就在谈论医疗成本已经到了不可持续的地步，大公司会说，我们需要公共选项，或者我们需要对保险进行更多监管。这是一种必然，因为钟摆不能摆得太远，联邦政府必须以某种方式更多地参与进来，
in the cost of insurance were more kind of spread out and shared from a public option or something. And that eventually this will have to happen was the conversation then because it's so unsustainable and it's becoming so cumbersome that it'll happen when the corporations want it to, because they're the ones with all the money in the lobbyists. It seems like now they're just being like, well, everyone's gonna be a good worker,
保险成本通过公共选项或其他方式进行分摊。当时人们谈论的是，这最终一定会发生，因为它太不可持续了，而且变得越来越繁琐。当大公司想要它发生时，它就会发生，因为他们是拥有所有资金和游说者的人。现在看起来他们只是觉得，好吧，每个人都会成为好员工，
everyone's gonna be working for cash at a bar. Everyone's gonna be working food service. You're gonna be delivering Uber Eats till your 40s. You're gonna be delivering Amazon package, Prime, whatever, contractor. And insurance just isn't part of the American dream. I guess you just need to die. And they sort of bypass that thing. It's not the system is more sustainable. It's just that like we have less hope, which is terrifying.
每个人都会在酒吧拿现金工作。每个人都会从事餐饮服务。你到40岁还在送Uber Eats。你还在送亚马逊包裹，Prime，无论什么合同工。保险不再是美国梦的一部分。我想你只能去死。他们绕过了那个问题。并不是系统变得更可持续了，只是我们拥有的希望变少了，这太可怕了。
I don't know. Yeah, yeah, no, it's so true. I think we, yeah, I think we have less hope. I think people can be working really hard and not have a good quality of life. And I think we've somehow decided that that's okay. Yeah, I think of, I have, what I've seen, I've mentioned that I have patients who like lose insurance and I don't see them for a while
我不知道。是的，确实如此。我想我们确实拥有的希望变少了。我认为人们可以非常努力地工作，却依然没有良好的生活质量。我想我们不知何故决定了这是可以接受的。是的，我想到我所看到的，我提到过我有患者失去了保险，我有一段时间没见到他们，
and then they kind of come back. And sometimes when they come back, they are working at Amazon warehouses and they do have insurance because that job pays $15 an hour or more. But working there is so predatory. So I often see patients with repetitive use injuries. I had to write a letter for a pregnant woman
然后他们又回来了。有时当他们回来时，他们在亚马逊仓库工作，他们确实有保险，因为那份工作每小时支付15美元或更多。但在那里工作太具有掠夺性了。所以我经常看到患有重复性劳损的患者。我不得不为一名孕妇写信，
to say that she could use the bathroom more than like once every like three hours or something that she was allotted to. Cause like everything they do is timed. And so it's like, it's awful. Like I have seen the really bad impacts of Amazon, my patients in terms of their health, but they want it because it does have health insurance
说她上厕所的次数应该比分配给她的每三个小时一次要多。因为他们所做的一切都是计时计量的。这太糟糕了。我看到了亚马逊对我患者健康的严重负面影响，但他们想要这份工作，因为它确实有医疗保险，这是他们悬挂的胡萝卜。这真是一个两难的境地，如果你受教育程度低或贫穷，你几乎不可能找到一份既有医疗福利又能让你拥有良好生活质量的稳定工作，这非常非常难。我真的看不出来，人们要么在工作……是的，我有一位女士在一家大型跨国公司工作，他们留不住员工，因为他们不
and it's this carrot that they dangle. And it's just like, ah, it's such a catch-22 that if you're a poorly educated or a poor person, it is nearly impossible for you to find a good stable job that with health benefits that is that allows you to have a good quality of life like it's very very hard I just don't really see it like you know people are you know either working yeah I have this woman who works at a big national corporation and they can't keep employees because they don't
给他们支付合理的工资，所以她每周工作70个小时，还要填补轮班空缺，她的员工在受苦，她自己也工作得非常努力，她确实有福利，但这是有代价的。所以，医疗保健确实嵌入在许多更大的其他问题中。好吧，作为给你们的最后一个问题，因为你们都在接触政策，我没看到什么好的政治路径。我的意思是，肯定有政党对任何形式的监管都更加敌视。但我也没看到民主党真的在推动这些东西。我的意思是，
pay them well so she's working like 70 hours a week and filling in shifts and her employees are suffering and she's working really hard and she does have benefits But it's like, you know at a cost. So yeah, it's health care is embedded in a lot of larger other issues Well, I guess and it was kind of a final question for you guys because you you know, but both are in encountering policy I mean, I don't see like a great political path I mean, there's like, definitely parties that are like more, a party that is like more hostile to any kind of regulation. But it's not like I see the Democratic Party really running with any of this stuff, either. I mean,
有时他们只是口头上说说，但并没有发生什么真正的事情。似乎所有拥有权力的人都只是蹲在控制这些东西的杠杆前，假装他们想按下去。但当他们有能力这样做时，却偏偏不按。那么你认为什么是有效的？什么能让事情变得不同？是社区那种自下而上的方法吗？还是用不同的方式去强迫权力机构做他们应该做的事？你觉得什么有效？支持民众的政策，而阿拉巴马州就是其中之一。所以我确实认为这与
sometimes they kind of give it lip service, but there's nothing that really happened that seems like it behooves everybody who has any kind of power to just sort of squat in front of the levers that control this stuff and pretend that they kind of want to press them. But when they have the ability to do it, just not. And so what do you think is effective? I mean, what is effective at getting things to be different? Is that more of a kind of community, you know, bottom up approach? Is it a different way to coerce power to do something that it should? I mean, what do you feel like is works? kind of pro people policies and Alabama is one of those states. I mean, and so I do think that that does have to do with
政党立场有关。我只是觉得，作为一个州，我们似乎对许多侵犯人权的行为等事情感到相当坦然。所以我想到我们的州监狱系统……谈论监狱医疗是一个完全独立且可怕的话题，我们可以在另一集里讨论。但无论如何，是的，我认为……解决办法是什么？
political party alignment. I mean, I just like that we as a state seem to be like pretty okay with a lot of like human rights abuses and things like that. And so like I think about our like state prison system and like and like exist. I talking about prison prison healthcare is a totally separate, terrifying thing anyways, that we could do another episode about. But anyway, yeah, so I think like, I do think that, yeah, what is the solution?
我的意思是，解决保险不足的办法是医疗补助扩张，这在其他州已经奏效了。所以我们的州只需要听取其他类似的南方州（如北卡罗来纳州、阿肯色州）的证词，并决定这就是我们想要的。这对人们有好处。但我认为这很难，因为我们的州立法者
I mean, the solution to like under insurance is Medicaid expansion and it's worked in other states. And so it's like our state just has to listen to the testimony of other similar southern states, like North Carolina, but in Arkansas, and just has to decide this is what we want. This is good for people. But I think it's so hard because our state lawmakers don't
似乎并不一定想做对人们有益的事情。他们想要推进的议程是……我认为这很难，因为我们的州立法者似乎并不一定想做对人们有益的事情。他们想要推进的议程，我认为只是为了……我不知道，真的想迎合全国性的政治。这与住在伯明翰、莫比尔或阿拉巴马州佛罗伦萨的生活毫无关系。你为什么要谈论这些全国性的东西？是的。你在谈论里根时代。但我记得我小时候也看到过这种情况，当克林顿上台，金里奇基本上说所有政治都是
really seem to necessarily want to do what's good for people. They want to advance agendas that are, I think it's so hard because our state lawmakers don't really seem to necessarily want to do what's good for people. They want to advance agendas that are, I think, just meant to, I don't know, really want to pander to national politics. Where it's like this has nothing to do with what it was like to live in Birmingham or Mobile or Florence, Alabama. You know, why are you talking about this national stuff? Yes. You're talking about the Reagan era But I think I saw that happen too as a kid when when Clinton came in and Gingrich was basically like all politics are
全国性的了，你知道，这是两支足球队。在此之前，确实是：“好吧，我想投票选审计长。这是民主党人，这是共和党人。我是共和党人，但民主党人有一些我喜欢的想法。”这只是个审计长，我为什么要关心他对总统的看法？在里根、撒切尔、80年代、90年代的重组之后，它确实变成了足球比赛。是的，完全同意你的看法。我认为答案是保持政治地方化，
National now, you know, these are the two football teams and before that it really was like, all right I want to vote for the comptroller. Here's the Democrat. Here's the Republican. I'm a Republican, but the Democrat has these ideas I like that, you know. It's a comptroller. Why would I care what he thinks about the president? And it sort of did become football around that Reagan, Thatcher, 80s, 90s realignment. Yeah, no, totally agree with you. I think the answer is keeping politics local
并参与到地方事务中。这就是我个人决定尝试做的事情，当时我心想：“天哪，这感觉真的很绝望。”我能做些什么呢？参与像Alabama Rise、Alabama Appleseed这样的组织，他们正在做明显有益的事情。比如Alabama Appleseed，他们废除了监狱管理者可以在喂养囚犯后将剩余的食品预算私吞的想法。这导致了——
and getting involved in kind of local. And that's like what I decided to try to do like personally when I when I was just like, gosh, this feels really hopeless. Like, what are some things that I can do and like getting involved in organizations like Alabama Rise, Alabama Apple Seed that like are doing things that are clearly good. Like Alabama Apple Seed, you know, got rid of the idea that jail managers could basically pocket extra money that was left over in the food budget after feeding inmates. And so that led to-
那是文章。今年，我从囚犯的口粮中私吞了大约20万美元的土豆片。我想任何政治派别的人都会说：“这不对。”我们不能开始……但这也很滑稽，我不在乎你的政治立场是什么。有些事情太可怕了，我们难道不能一起嘲笑它吗？所以我认为答案就是这样。我认为答案是：嘿，让我们尝试在小范围内改善事情，或者像降低我们正在缓慢削减的杂货税。
That's articles. This year, I pocketed like $200,000 from potato flakes from the hands of the prisoners. And I think anyone across the political divide can be like, that's not good. Like, you know, like we can't start But also it's like comically funny, like I don't care what your politics are. Like some of this stuff is like so horrible. Like, can't we just laugh at it together? And so like, that is what I think the answer is. I think the answer is like, hey, let's try to like make things better in small ways or like reducing the grocery tax that we're slowly chipping.
谁想支付杂货税？我记得刚来这里时心想：“什么？还有杂货税？”宾夕法尼亚州不对杂货征税。它不对衣服征税。它不对基本生活用品征税。我当时觉得，住在这里就像在购买杂货时多付了10%的钱。这可是一大笔钱。所以，我认为答案是在每个人都能达成共识的小问题上团结起来，因为正如你所说，
He wants to pay grocery tax. I remember coming here and being like, what, there's grocery tax? Like Pennsylvania doesn't tax groceries. It doesn't tax clothes. Like, you know, it doesn't tax essential items. And like I was like, it was like, wow, living here is like a 10% increase in, in, in paying for groceries. And that's, that's a lot. So yeah, so I think like, the answer is coming together on small issues that everyone can agree on, because like, everyone can agree on stuff, you know, like you said,
有时这很滑稽，但有时就像杂货税一样，没有人想付这个钱，这根本没道理。让我们尝试废除它。所以我认为这就是目前的答案。也许未来情况会改变，政治分歧会减少，会有更好的答案。但目前的答案，我认为是致力于这些小事情。好吧，我听到很多关于政治分歧和敌意有多大、我们有多分裂的议论。
it's sometimes it's funny, but sometimes it's just like grocery tax, like, no one wants to pay this, like, it doesn't make sense. Let's try to get rid of that. And so I think that's the answer right now. Maybe things will change and we'll have less political division and there will be better answers. But the answer right now, I think, is to work on these smaller things. Well, I think there I hear like a lot of opining about how they there's so much political dissension and hostility and we're more divided or something.
这就像是……也许我们确实如此，但真正的政治问题，我听到每个人都在说同样的事情。就好像我们必须为了别的东西而进行政治斗争。当我看到人们谈论礼貌时，他们会说：“这家伙很粗鲁”或者“这家伙怎么样”。从物质上讲，他们做了什么？
And it's just kind of like, I mean, maybe like we are, well, but the real political issues, I hear everybody saying the same thing about, like it's almost like we must have politics for something else. Like when I see people talking about manners, they're like, well, this guy's rude or this guy's whatever. And it's like materially, what did they do?
我不在乎他们说话是否像你，长相是否像你，无论如何，他们做了什么？你不在乎他们说话是否像你，长相是否像你，无论如何，他们是否做了你喜欢的事情？有一种需要让政客们成为大理石超级英雄的倾向，他们说：“不，你要选出那些去激励和代表的人，然后孩子们看着他们。”不，他们不应该是酷的。他们应该是来修路和提供食物的。如果他们没做到，我不在乎。那是他们的工作。所以我不知道。所以这可能不是什么大的重组。这可能只是专注于每个人都关心的事情，
Like, I don't care if they talk like you and look like you and whatever, like, did they do? You know, like I don't care I'm like if they talk like you and look like you and whatever like did they do something that you like and There's this kind of need to make politicians I think like marble superheroes where they're like No, you elect people that go out and inspire and they represent and then the kids look at them and like No, like they're not supposed to be cool. They're supposed to make roads and food. And if they haven't done that, I don't care. You know, that's their job. And I don't know. So it's almost like it may not be that big of a realignment. It may just be a focusing on what everybody cares
而不是这种游戏。我完全同意。这就是我写那篇文章时尝试做的，试图呼吁人们：“看，你们所有人都认识会从医疗补助扩张中受益的人。”我认为每个读到这篇文章的人都会想：“哦，我认识的人会从中受益。”所以，如果是这样的话，让我们团结起来，帮助那些需要这种帮助的同胞。这就是我想通过文章做的，只是试图鼓励人们思考：“哦，在这些情况下，确实有人需要帮助，他们可能不需要永远被帮助，
about, you know, and instead of this kind of game. I totally agree. And that's kind of what I tried to do with this article was try to like, appeal to people to be like Look like they're all of you know someone who would benefit from Medicaid expansion Everyone who's reading this I think would think oh, there's someone I know who would have benefited from this And so like like if that's the case like let's all band together and help our fellow citizens who need this help. And so like that's what I wanted to do with the article is kind of just try to encourage people to think like oh, there are these people in these situations that need help and they may not need help forever,
但他们现在需要帮助。如果我们想要一个健康、经济强大的州，这就是我们所有人可以共同努力的目标。”所以，总之，非常感谢。我想尊重你们的时间，所以有什么我们没谈到但你们想在最后补充的吗？你们能给我那些组织的链接吗？这样我可以把它们放在节目说明里，还有什么人们听完之后可能想去看看的吗？是的，我绝对可以。我可以……哦，抱歉，我可以放那些……你现在不必做。
but they need help now and like if we want a healthy, economically strong state, like that's what we can all work to do so that is to do this thing so anyway well thank you so much I want to be respectful of you guys' time so is there anything that we don't get to that you want to put in at the end and can you also give me the links to those organizations so that I can put those in the show notes and anything else that people might want to check out after listening to this Yeah, I definitely can um I um, I can Oh, sorry, I can put those Um, then you don't have to do it now
我只是想确保听众知道，如果他们感兴趣，可以获得更多相关信息。是的，Alabama Rise很棒。他们在让每个人了解和掌握那些核心问题方面做得非常好，包括目前正在发生的事情、何时进行游说、该与谁交谈、何时出现在州议会大厦等等。所以他们确实在做很多我认为人们在说“哦，我不想参与，因为我不知道怎么做”时所回避的工作。他们提供了很多“如何做”的指导，并真正支持你以一种有意义的方式积极参与政治。
Just I want to make sure listeners know that they can get more information about that if they if they're interested Yeah, alabama rise is great They do a really good job of keeping everyone informed and up to date on what those do a really good job of keeping everyone informed and up to date on what those core issues are that are currently happening and when to lobby and who to talk to and when to show up at the State House and all those things. So they really are doing a lot of the work that I think a lot of people don't want when they're like, oh, I don't want to get involved that because I don't know how they do a lot of the how and really support you and being able to you know, really Actively engage in a political way. That's meaningful
有什么我们没谈到但你们觉得相关且需要包含的信息吗？是的，我只是想回到鼓励人们不要对政治感到绝望这一点上，并说：“是的，Alabama Rise或Alabama Appleseed，去了解州议会中正在讨论的法案，给你的州议员打电话。”积极参与公民事务感觉真的很好，你可以改变现状。比如，刚才有一项关于青少年接受医疗服务时父母同意年龄的法律。它原本要从14岁提高到18岁，这对许多独自去看医生、因为他们会开车或有祖父母
Anything we don't get to that you feel like is is information that is relevant and it needs to needs to be included Yeah, I just would like get back to like encouraging people to not be hopeless about Politics and to kind of just say like, yeah, Alabama, rise or Alabama, Appleseed, just learning about learning about bills that are in the state house, calling your state legislators, that feels really good to be civically active and you can, you know, turn the needle. So there was just a law about age of parental consent for teens receiving healthcare services. And it was going to go from 14 to 18, which would have been challenging for a lot of teens who are going to the doctor alone because they can drive or they have a grandparent
更多地参与他们的护理但不是法定监护人的青少年来说，将是一个挑战。通过大量的倡导，该法律从18岁降回到了16岁，这很好。这样他们就不会阻碍青少年获得护理。这只是一个例子，医学界围绕这个问题进行了倡导，结果改变了。所以，你可以对你关心的问题产生影响，
who's more involved in their care and that they're not the legal guardian. And through a lot of advocacy, that law was brought down from 18 to 16, which is good. So that they cannot impede access to care for teens. So that's just an example, like there was advocacy surrounding that in the medical community and that was changed. So like you can make a difference with issues that matter to you,
可能不是私人保险这种巨大的问题，但较小的、同样重要的问题是可以的。所以我只是鼓励人们不要感到无助，并与更多地方或州级的组织接触。是的，我也认为，我之所以想赞扬你的文章并表示感谢，是因为在医学界，
not these huge issues, probably like private insurance, but smaller ones that are also important. So I would just encourage people to not be helpless and to get engaged with more local or more state-based organizations. Yeah, and I think too, one of the reasons I wanted to celebrate your article and say thank you is a lot of times there's a culture in medicine
医生之间有一种文化，他们不想打破常规。我理解他们不这样做有很多原因，因为批评同事或说不同的话会带来巨大的责任风险。但这加剧了人们对医生怀有敌意和不理解的问题，
with medical doctors where they don't wanna break ranks. And I understand like a lot of the reasons why they don't because there's a lot of times there's a culture in medicine with medical doctors where they don't want to break ranks. And I understand like a lot of the reasons why they don't because there's a ton of liability in basically criticizing your colleagues or saying different things. But it contributes to that problem of people being hostile to doctors and people not understanding,
因为私人保险公司里拒绝报销的那个人最终也是有医学学位的。当那些出于正确理由从事医疗工作的医生因为害怕责任而不去批评这一点时，我认为这加剧了问题。能够进行这些对话，
because the person at the top of the private insurance company that's rejecting the thing ultimately has a medical degree. And when the doctors who are in it for the right reasons don't criticize that because of a fear of liability and the same reasons a lot of people don't speak out, I think it reinforces that problem. And to kind of have these conversations
公开诚实地讨论思想经济，并围绕这些事情进行自由的讨论和辩论是很重要的。医疗专业人员说出这些话很重要。不仅仅是在你上了NPR、写了书、有了数百万美元之后，无论是在你职业生涯的开始，
and be open and honest about an economy of ideas and to be able to kind of have free discussion and debate around these things is important. It's important for medical professionals to say these things. And not just after you've gone on NPR and written a book and you have millions of dollars and it doesn't matter at the beginning of your career,
还是职业生涯的中期，这都很重要。所以我们非常感谢你所做的一切以及你继续在做的事情。谢谢。是的，我想我只是想让我的患者知道我关心他们。我想他们确实知道。我们非常感谢你所做的一切以及你继续在做的事情。谢谢。是的，我想我只是想让我的患者知道我关心他们。我想他们确实知道，而且大多数医生确实非常关心他们的患者。但是，是的，我认为有时人们害怕说出来，你知道，我想
the middle of your career. So we really appreciate what you did and what you continue to do. Thank you. Yeah, I think I just, I want my patients to know that I care for them. I think they do know that. We really appreciate what you did and what you continue to do. Thank you. Yeah, I think I just I want my patients to know that I care for them. I think they do know that and but that most doctors do care a lot for their patients. And but yeah, I think sometimes there's a fear of speaking out and you know, I guess
你可以解雇我，但初级保健医生需求量很大。我想我可以在别处工作。但我认为他们不会。但是，是的，我认为让患者知道我们正在经历什么以及存在哪些障碍也很重要。很多医生精疲力竭，然后去为联合健康集团（United Healthcare）工作，那是全国最大的医生雇主。这太可悲了。所以每当我结束与他们的同行评审电话时，我总是说……是的，每当我结束与他们的同行评审时，我总是说，我希望你意识到你所做的事情
you could fire me, but I could be a primary care is in demand. I think I'm somewhere else. But I I don't think they will. But yeah, I think it's important for patients to know what we're going through too, and that there are barriers. And a lot of patients, a lot of doctors burn out and then go work for United Healthcare, which is the largest employer of doctors in the country. And it's so sad. So whenever I end a peer to peer with them, I always say egg, you know. Yeah, whenever I end a peer to peer with them, I always say, I hope you appreciate that what you're doing
正在导致像我这样真正关心患者的医生精疲力竭。我希望你为此感到难过。这就是我结束同行评审的方式。如果这能让你感觉好点，那是我能做的一点小事。是的。我当时正在和某人通电话，我妻子看着我……
is contributing to burnout for doctors like me who are actually caring for patients. And like, I hope you feel bad about that. And that's how I end my period of period of perioders. And if that makes you feel good, that's like a little thing that I can do. Yeah. I was on the phone with somebody, my wife cleared at me,
正在导致像我这样真正照顾病人的医生精疲力竭。而且，我希望你为此感到愧疚。这就是我结束我那段时期的方式。如果这让你感觉良好，那也算是我能做的一点小事。是的。我当时正在和某人通电话，我妻子对我大喊大叫，
but I was on the phone with somebody with a tech support bureaucracy thing, and I was explaining something to them, and they were like, what do you want? And I was like, I just want you to feel bad. What? Yeah. Yeah, no, I know, I just, yeah, yeah.
但我当时正在和技术支持部门的人通电话，我向他们解释了一些事情，他们问我到底想要什么？我说，我只是想让你感到愧疚。什么？是啊，我知道，我只是……是啊，是啊。
When retired doctors do that, it kills me. I'm just like, what the heck? Like, you should find some other side gig like driving for Uber or something. Like, that's not what I'm doing. Well, thank you so much for coming on. This was a joy. Hopefully we can do this again around other topics. We were hoping to have the podcast studio by this point, but connecting visually works pretty well. So hopefully we can do kind of more local issues and local guests. And we really appreciate your work. You can find out more information about Haley and her practice on the TapRite website. And then we will link to everything that Dr. Echenrod mentioned and then also her practice page in the show notes too, if you all
当退休医生那样做时，我真的受不了。我心想，搞什么鬼？你应该找点别的副业，比如开优步之类的。我可不是在做那个。非常感谢你能来参加节目。这真是一次愉快的交流。希望我们以后能围绕其他话题再次合作。我们本希望到这个时候能有播客工作室了，但视频连线效果也还不错。所以希望我们能讨论更多本地议题，邀请更多本地嘉宾。我们非常感谢你的工作。你可以在TapRite网站上找到更多关于海莉及其诊所的信息。我们会在节目说明中附上埃琴罗德医生提到的所有内容以及她诊所的页面，如果你想查看的话。
want to check that out. The next podcast will be a guided meditation on anger, no relationship between the content here and completely random series of so enjoy that and we will hopefully talk to you again soon. Thank you so much. It was really fun to talk to you both and have a good rest of your day. Music Good morning my darling, I've been telling you this To let you know I'm sorry you're sick Tears of sorrow won't do you no good I'd be your doctor if only I could You can be sure you won't do you no good I'll be your doctor if only I could
下一期播客将是一次关于愤怒的引导式冥想，这与本期内容毫无关联，纯属巧合，敬请期待，希望我们很快能再次交流。非常感谢。和你们两位聊天真的很开心，祝你们余下的一天过得愉快。音乐：亲爱的，早上好，我一直在告诉你，让你知道我很抱歉你生病了，悲伤的泪水对你没有帮助，如果可以的话，我真想成为你的医生，你可以确定你不会独自受苦。
You can be sure you won't suffer alone I'd swim the ocean so the deepest canal To get to you darling just to make sure you're well There's no place on earth that I won't hasten to go To cool the fever this I want you to know There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以确定你不会独自受苦，我会游过海洋，穿过最深的运河，来到你身边，亲爱的，只为确保你安好。这世上没有我不会赶去的地方，为了帮你退烧，这一点我想让你知道。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。